bonjour aujourd'hui je vous présente
tena izy côte qui est un journaliste
américain d'une quarantaine d'années
donc c'est son premier ouvrage est donc
là il va écrire une lettre à son fils
d'une quinzaine d'années sur la
condition est sur la position des hommes
noirs dans la société américaine
donc il prend en fait lui comme contexte
position à lui en tant que jeune donc
l'éducation qu'il a pu recevoir de son
père qui lui descendait des esclaves et
donc tout tout son vécu et tous ont
ressenti vis-à-vis de la position du
corps noir ce qu'ils utilisent
extrêmement souvent ce terme là de corps
noir dans la poésie dans la société
américaine et donc on voit en fait c'est
plus une explication sur le contexte de
la naissance du racisme aux états unis
que sur quelles sont les solutions que
j'ai qu'il faut y apporter c'est juste
voilà un acte de fait sur la position du
noir dans la société américaine
ce qui finalement est très intéressant
dans ce livre enfin c'est de voir les
évolutions déjà son père tanaisie côte a
connu une situation du noir dans dans la
société
lui en a connu forcément une différente
son fils va forcément aussi on connaît
une différente parce que déjà il ya un
président américain noir et donc on va
lasser ces évolutions la de la société
américaine et du racisme et le la
préface qui est fait par mon bon coup
qui dit quand même qu'il ya des
différences entre la société française
et la société américaine
on n'a pas les mêmes façons de gérer ce
racisme la vis à vis des noirs mais qui
a quand même des ponts qui existe et ça
permet quand même de pousser aussi la
réflexion sur notre société à nous et
sur ce que devient la france et son
racisme
alors je présente le nouveau roman de
kéthévane davrichewy l'autre joseph aux
éditions sabine wespieser pour
lesquelles j'ai vraiment eu un gros coup
de coeur en fait elle raconte l'histoire
de son arrière grand père joseph
davrichewy qu'est né à la fin du 19e
siècle en géorgie dans le même village
et quelques années après à joseph
beaucoup plus connu celui là qui sera
joseph staline donc elle raconte en fait
l'histoire dans une géorgie encore très
rurale de ces deux joseph qui vont avoir
une vie quand même assez parallèle dans
une effectivement géorgie et rural
également sous la coupe d'un d'un voisin
quand même assez omniprésent qui est la
russie d'accord et elle raconte
notamment comment va naître leur leurs
convictions politiques leur ferveur
surtout révolutionnaire est ce qu'ils
vont devenir tous les deux donc on
connaît ce que demain ce qui va arriver
effectivement à joseph staline un petit
peu moins vivement pour son
arrière-grand-père qui en soi va être un
vrai avoir une vie de vrai personnage de
roman il va être espion il va il va
qu'on devait être faire faire partie des
premiers pilotes de la première guerre
mondiale
voilà donc c'est un livre absolument
passionnant qui entremêle vie enfin là
la petite et la grande histoire assez
sobre comme écriture assez assez
efficace je dirais que c'est
effectivement assez assez court
passionnant aussi sur l'héritage
familial parce qu'en fait elle mène à la
fois une enquête sur cet arrière grand
père qui est un personnage en fait
plutôt trouble dans sa famille elle ne
savait pas très bien où il ya beaucoup
de choses qu'on ne connaissait pas de
lui même si lui même avait écrit un
livre sur son enfance et qu'il avait
côtoyé avec citadine voilà un superbe
roman moi j'ai eu vraiment un bon coup
de coeur passionnant on apprend beaucoup
de choses
voilà donc l'autre joseph de kéthévane
davrichewy
je vous présente je suis chars liberté
d' arthur ténor qui est un livre
jeunesse dédié aux enfants d'à peu près
douze ans entre 10 et 12 ans et c'est
donc un livre qui est vraiment qui suit
l'actualité qui prend toutes les
thématiques qu'on a nous actuellement là
au niveau de la société qui sont la
liberté d'expression et la laïcité
donc c'est une histoire de collégiens
qui sont en classe de 3e qui souhaitent
monter un petit fanzine à 3 et donc
c'est toutes les embûches et août tous
les soucis qu'ils vont rencontrer pour
monter ce journal donc ils vont réussir
finalement a publié avec la avec
l'accord du proviseur et après par
contre ça va être tout les réactions en
chaîne qui vont avoir qui vont avoir
finalement en face d'eux par rapport à
ce que ce soit les personnes de leur
classe où finalement le corps enseignant
enfin tout ce que finalement on tout les
thèmes toutes les thématiques de société
qui n'ont qui ont qui ont lieu
actuellement
l'intérêt de ce livre c'est qu'on y voit
vraiment toutes les thématiques donc il
ya cette histoire de nous mettre le
curseur sur la liberté individuelle
jusqu'à où on peut donner les
informations et jusqu'à où on peut être
finalement impartiale vis-à-vis
l'information il ya aussi ça traite
aussi de la religion donc qu'est ce que
la laïcité
est ce que nous on peut accepter que
l'autre soit différent ou pas et donc
c'est vraiment toutes ces thématiques
qui seront abordées d'un point de vue
finalement de collégiens mais qui
peuvent aussi ça convient tout le monde
finalement ce livre que ce soit les
enfants qui vont avoir une première
lecture comme ça mais les parents aussi
qui vont découvrir pas mal de choses à
travers ce livre donc le nouveau roman
d'anne des règles de sa majesté maman
c'est un livre hommage à sa maman elle a
toujours écrit sur sa famille dans tous
ses autres romans mais là c'est vraiment
un livre pour sa mère au moment où elle
est hospitalisée
donc on sait dès le départ que sa maman
va mourir mais c'est absolument pas dans
le pathos plutôt un livre tendre où elle
raconte cette relation mère fille qui
n'a pas toujours été facile c'était pas
une maman forcément tendre mais voilà
elle se plie en quatre pour ses enfants
elle essaie de leur faire un festin avec
deux trois aliments qui traînait dans le
frigo
elle les a éduqués à la lecture etc
donc elle raconte cette relation il ya
des moments où elle raconte ses
souvenirs avec sa mère et puis des
moments d'échangés entre sa mère et elle
à l'hôpital
elle dénonce aussi les systèmes de santé
en norvège qui n'a rien à envier des
systèmes de santé de pied de pays du
tiers monde c'est vraiment très violent
voilà c'est un très beau livre s'étendre
c'est drôle c'est touchant mais c'est
absolument pas triste malgré le sujet